welcome you to cbs mornings we're going
to begin though with powerful testimony
and new scrutiny of the fbi over the
sexual abuse case against larry nassar
now we are used to seeing ali raisman
simone biles maggie nichols and michaela
maroney on podiums representing the best
of what america has to offer but
yesterday these women sat together
side by side to testify about the
american government failing them the
dark side of their sport and its
terrible terrible consequences they
spoke about being molested by the former
team doctor and gave a searing
indictment ensearing is a word of how
the fbi and us gymnastics handled this
case at least 70 athletes have come
forward to say that nassar abused them
after after the bureau was told of these
allegations jeff because is outside the
fbi headquarters in washington with more
on this story jeff i watched the
testimony it was heartbreaking yesterday
to me good morning to you
yeah gail it was really something to see
and with the fbi's reputation
on the line the director offered a
personal apology to the gymnast and
their families but the athletes say that
is not enough they want the agents
involved in the mishandled case
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law
to be clear i blame larry nassar
and i also blame
an entire system
that enabled and
perpetrated his abuse
in a heart-wrenching four-hour hearing
on capitol hill wednesday olympic star
simone biles and her former teammates
described the sexual abuse by former usa
gymnastics dr larry nassar
i then told the fbi about tokyo the day
he gave me a sleeping pill for the plane
ride to then work on me later that night
that evening i was naked completely
alone with him on top of me molesting me
for hours gold medalist michaela moroney
who was just 13 when she was first
abused slammed the fbi for not only
failing to protect them but also aiding
in the alleged cover-up by not taking
immediate action from my report they
allowed
a child molester to go free for more
than a year and this inaction directly
allowed nassar's abuse to continue
what is the point
of reporting abuse if our own fbi agents
are going to take it upon themselves to
bury that report in a drawer maggie
nichols was the first to report nassar's
abuse to usa gymnastics in 2015.
i reported my abuse to usa gymnastics
over six years ago
and still
my family and i received few answers and
have even more questions about how this
was allowed to occur it is estimated
that nassar who was serving a more than
100-year sentence
abused at least 70 more women and girls
after nichols told the fbi two-time
olympian ali raisman the fbi and others
within both usag and usopc knew that
nassar molested children and did nothing
to restrict his access it was like
serving innocent children up to a
pedophile
on a silver platter fbi director chris
ray apologized for the bureau's failures
i'm sorry that so many different people
let you down over and over again
and i'm especially sorry
that there were people at the fbi who
had their own chance to stop this
monster back in 2015 and failed and that
is inexcusable
it never should have happened and we're
doing everything in our power to make
sure it never happens again
the inspector general said yesterday
that he referred the fbi agent's conduct
to the justice department for criminal
prosecution the question is why didn't
the department of justice do anything
why didn't it bring charges
members of the department of justice the
ag the deputy attorney general they were
asked to testify yesterday they were not
there but we're hearing now
that they are expected on the hill next
month usa gymnastics did not comment
gail
boy jeff there are a lot of why
questions in this case thank you so much